The story of the slot machine is one of intrigue,
theft, controversy, and murder.
Okay, not murder, but everything else.
And it starts in Bavaria….
Augustinus Charles Fey was the youngest of
sixteen children born in 1862 in the small
village of Vohringen, Bavaria which sits at
the edge of the Alps.
Early on, he displayed an interest in mechanics,
following his brothers’ footsteps and working
in a farm tool factory in Munich.
At fifteen, August hit the road (apparently
fearful of his strict father and not wanting
to serve in the military) and walked across
Europe.
He stopped in France for about three years,
working as an intercom equipment manufacturer,
and then made his way to a British shipyard
(approximately 750 miles and an English channel
away from home), where he settled down for
five years as a nautical instrument maker.
Several years before, August’s uncle (his
mother’s brother) had moved to and settled
in New Jersey.
The family received letters from him talking
of fortune and the good life America provided.
So, August saved his money and made the pilgrimage
to the United States.
He arrived in New Jersey and lived with his
uncle’s family in Hoboken (the birth place
of baseball), but quickly made the decision
to try his hand out west in the “lawless”
town of San Francisco.
He arrived there approximately in 1884/1885
at around 23 years old, right when the city
was attempting to change itself, for better
and worse.
In 2013, maps of San Francisco were uncovered
from the late 19th century.
These maps showed numerous gambling halls,
opium dens, and brothels dotting the city,
with each vice-ridden location color-coded
on the maps.
Despite this, little was done at this time
by the local government and police force about
these illegal establishments.
In this environment, Fey used his skills as
a mechanic and found a job at California Electric
Works (later Western Electric, which went
defunct in 1995).
He worked as an instrument maker and while
doing this befriended a German foreman, Theodore
Holtz, who will come into this story again
later.
It was also about this time that he met Marie
Christine Volkmar, the daughter of a cigar
shop owner, with whom he fell in love with.
Unfortunately, he contracted consumption,
aka tuberculosis (see: Why Tuberculosis was
Called Consumption), and hit the road again,
this time for warmer weather in Mexico.
While there, his health did not improve, so
he returned to San Fran, thinking if he was
going to die, it might as well be near the
woman he loved.
He miraculously got better (potentially due
to the controversial use of creosote, obtained
through the distillation of tar) and married
Marie in 1889.
They would go on to have four children together.
To top off the metamorphosis going on in his
life, August Charles Fey changed his name
to Charles Fey, reportedly because he hated
being called “Gus.”
At this point, Fey began tinkering with creating
and inventing his own mechanical devices.
Always a fan of making money, he frequented
the gambling halls of San Francisco and noticed
the so-called “nickel-in-the-slot” machines
that were rapidly becoming popular.
These machines were much closer to vending
machines than to what we think of slot machines
today, dispensing cigars or drink tickets.
These also usually required a human, the cigar
shop owner or barkeep, to give you your prize.
The most popular ones were the poker machines
that would actually flip real playing cards
on five reels, revealing the hand.
The better the hand, the more drink/cigar
tickets you earned.
These types of machines were so ubiquitous
that a San Francisco Daily News headline noted,
“Fiveteen Hundred Swindling Machines in
One City!”
In 1893, Fey thought he could make a better
gambling machine.
His work friend Theodore Holtz introduced
him to another German who was working at California
Electric Works, Gustav Friedrich Wilhelm Schultze.
On August 8, 1893, Schultze had patented his
own “coin-controlled apparatus,” called
the “Horseshoe.”
This was the first US patent issued for a
gambling machine and was the first to somewhat
resemble what we now know as a modern slot
machine.
In fact, some historians have argued that
Schultz, not Fey, should be the one known
as the “Thomas Edison of slot machines.”
We will come back to that later.
Either way, Fey was impressed and “inspired”
by the Horseshoe and went to work on his own
coin-controlled apparatus.
In 1894, Fey designed a version of the Horseshoe,
quite simply the same machine, but with a
better mechanical reel, and asked Holtz to
be his equal business partner (and not Schultz.)
Holtz agreed and they both quit their jobs
at California Electric, setting up shop as
“Holtz and Fey Electric Works” at 39 Stevenson
Street.
Purposefully, they positioned their shop close
to Schultz’s shop, who had also quit his
job to make gambling machines.
This should have set up a rivalry, except
for the fact that Holtz and Fey were also
selling leftover parts to Schultz, presumably
because Schultz had no clue that they were
also making gambling machines and had essentially
stolen his idea.
In any event, in the basement of his house
in 1895, Fey completed his next mechanical
wonder, an even more modified version of the
Horseshoe he called the “4-11-44” in homage
to a popular lottery game at the time called
“Policy,” in which the rare winning sequence
was 4-11-44.
This machine is one of the reasons so many
give Fey the credit for inventing the slot
machine.
It was a three-disc floor machine and was
unlike any other ever created because instead
of spitting out tokens or slips, it had the
ability to dispense actual coins.
They put it in a local San Francisco saloon
and it was a hit and a huge money maker.
Fey and Holtz went to work producing more,
but before they got very far, Fey, once again,
went packing.
Fey sold his share of his company with Holtz
to start his own company, Charles Fey & Company.
(Holtz also founded his own company and called
it “Novelty Machine Works”.)
In 1897, Fey further staked his claim as the
“Thomas Edison of slot machines,” when
he devised the Card Bell slot machine, a “three-reel,
staggered-stop machine with automatic payout.”
Essentially, what it did was stagger the stops
– first one reel, then the second, and then
the third – just like modern slot machines,
creating suspense, drama, and excitement.
At first, he used playing card symbols, but
two years later, he replaced them with stars
and bells and called it the “Liberty Bell”
slot machine.
With ten symbols on each reel and ten stops,
it allowed for numerous combinations.
It was unlike anything else on the market,
including Schultz’s machines.
It should be noted here that, technically,
slot machines at this time were illegal (though,
most law officials rarely policed them).
As such, even though Schultz was awarded a
patent in 1893 for his machine, when he tried
to sue Holtz (he did name several other defendants
in his documents, including Fey, but Holtz
was the main defendant), the courts ruled
that the patent didn’t protect him because
a gambling machine was illegal.
Because of this, the gambling and slot machine
industry, from then on, was a bit like the
wild wild west – ideas, designs, and concepts
were stolen right and left.
As for Fey, he never patented any of his machines
nor sold or leased them.
He would operate them himself by making agreements
with the proprietors (bars, cigar shops, etc.)
for a 50/50 split of the profits.
In the end, Fey’s machines were a hit and
became the “the largest slot operation in
the country during
the early 1900s.”